C'est très, très difficile de conclure --
de parler à la fin d'une conférence comme celle-ci.
Parce que tout le monde a parlé, tout a été dit.
Donc j'ai pensé que ce qui pourrait être utile c'est de nous rappeler
certaines choses qui se sont passées ici,
et ensuite peut-être de présenter certaines idées avec lesquelles nous pouvons repartir,
et que nous pouvons faire progresser et sur lesquelles nous pouvons travailler.
C'est ce que j'aimerais essayer de faire.
Nous sommes venus ici en disant que nous voulions parler de "l'Afrique: chapitre suivant".
Mais nous parlons de "l'Afrique: chapitre suivant"
parce que nous regardons l'ancien chapitre et le chapitre actuel -- ce que nous voyons là --
et nous disons que ce n'est pas tellement bon.
La photo que je viens de vous montrer, ainsi que cette photo, de sécheresse, de mort et de maladie,
c'est cela qu'on voit d'habitude.
Ce que nous voulons regarder c'est "l'Afrique: chapitre suivant."
Et c'est cela: un Africain en bonne santé, souriant et beau.
Et je pense que ça vaut la peine de nous rappeler ce que nous avons entendu
tout au long de la conférence depuis le tout premier jour,
où j'ai entendu que toutes les statistiques importantes ont été fournies --
qui montrent là où nous en sommes maintenant,
comment le continent se porte beaucoup mieux.
Et c'est important car ainsi nous avons un socle sur lequel construire.
Donc je ne vais pas passer trop de temps --
juste pour vous montrer, rafraîchir vos souvenirs--
que nous sommes ici pour: "l'Afrique: chapitre suivant" parce que pour la première fois,
il y a vraiment un socle sur lequel construire.
Ça va vraiment bien pour nous --
le continent croît à des taux dont on pensait que cela n'arriverait jamais.
Après des décennies de croissance à 2 pour cent, nous en sommes maintenant à 5 pour cent
et nous allons arriver -- selon les projections -- à 6 et même 7 pour cent.
Et l'inflation a diminué.
La dette extérieure -- un sujet sur lequel je peux parler longtemps
car j'ai personnellement travaillé sur une des plus grandes dettes du continent --
a diminué de façon spectaculaire.
Vous savez, comme vous pouvez le voir, de presque --
de presque 50 milliards elle est descendue autour de 12 ou 13 milliards.
Et ça c'est une énorme réussite.
Vous savez, nous avons constitué des réserves. Pourquoi est-ce important?
Parce que ça met en valeur nos économies, ça met en valeur nos devises
et ça crée un socle sur lequel on peut planifier et construire, y compris des entreprises.
On peut aussi affirmer que tout cela fait avancer les choses
parce que les flux d'investissements privés ont augmenté.
Je veux encore vous rappeler --
je sais que vous avez déjà vu ces statistiques --
que de presque 6 milliards nous sommes maintenant passés à environ 18 milliards.
En 2005, les entrées en devises -- je prends juste un pays, le Nigeria--
ont monté en flèche -- monté en flèche est trop exagéré,
mais elles ont augmenté de façon spectaculaire.
Et c'est ce qui se passe aussi dans beaucoup d'autres pays.
Pourquoi est-ce important? Parce que cela montre la confiance.
Que la population a maintenant confiance pour ramener --
si votre peuple dans la diaspora ramène son argent,
cela montre aux autres que, regardez,
la confiance est en train de naître dans votre pays.
Et au lieu d'une fuite de capitaux, nous avons maintenant un apport net de capitaux.
Et pourquoi tout cela est-il important? De devoir aller vite?
Il est important que nous construisions ce socle,
que nous ayons le président, Kikwete, et d'autres dirigeants qui disent,
"Regardez, nous devons agir différemment."
Parce que nous sommes confrontés à un défi.
62 pour cent de notre population a moins de 24 ans.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie?
Cela signifie que nous devons nous concentrer sur la façon dont notre jeunesse
va s'engager dans des activités productives dans la vie.
Il faut se concentrer sur comment créer des emplois,
s'assurer qu'ils ne tombent pas malade, qu'ils reçoivent une éducation.
Mais plus que tout, qu'ils s'engagent dans la vie de façon productive,
et qu'ils créent le genre d'environnement productif
dans nos pays qui permet de faire avancer les choses.
Et vous savez, pour soutenir cela, je viens juste de --
une des choses que j'ai faites depuis que j'ai quitté le gouvernement
a été de démarrer un institut de sondage d'opinion au Nigéria.
Dans la plupart de nos pays, il n'y a même pas de sondages d'opinion.
Les gens ne s'expriment pas.
Il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir ce que les gens veulent.
Une des choses que nous leur avons demandées récemment était de nommer leur plus grand problème.
Comme dans tous les autres pays où cela a été fait,
l'emploi est le plus grand problème.
Je veux laisser ça là haut et y revenir plus tard.
Mais avant que j'en arrive à cette diapositive, je voulais juste récapituler cela avec vous.
Et dire que pour moi, l'étape suivante de la construction de ce socle
qui nous permet maintenant d'avancer --
et nous ne devons pas prendre cela à la légère.
Il y a seulement 5, 6 ou 7 ans --
nous ne pouvions même pas parler du chapitre suivant parce que nous étions dans l'ancien chapitre.
Nous n'allions nulle part.
Les économies ne croissaient pas.
Nous avions une croissance par habitant négative.
Le cadre et les fondations microéconomiques pour pouvoir avancer
n'existaient même pas.
Donc n'oublions pas que ça a été difficile de construire cela,
y compris tout ce que nous avons essayé de faire au Nigéria, et à quoi Dele a fait référence.
Créer notre propre programme pour résoudre nos problèmes, comme lutter contre la corruption,
construire des institutions, stabiliser la microéconomie.
Donc maintenant nous avons ce socle sur lequel nous pouvons construire.
Et cela nous ramène au débat qui a eu lieu ici:
l'aide internationale par opposition au secteur privé, ou aux échanges commerciaux, etc...
Et quelqu'un s'est levé pour dire -- ce qui est frustrant
c'est que ça a été un débat simpliste.
Et ça ne devrait pas être le sujet du débat.
C'est se lancer dans le mauvais débat.
La question ici est de savoir comment créer un partenariat qui implique des donneurs gouvernementaux,
le secteur privé et de simples citoyens africains
qui prennent en charge leur propre vie?
Comment pouvons-nous combiner tout cela?
Pour faire avancer notre continent, pour faire ce qui a besoin d'être fait,
ce dont je parle - que les jeunes trouvent un emploi.
Faire preuve de créativité sur ce continent,
comme ce que vous avez vu ici.
Alors j'ai peur que vous vous soyez un peu lancés dans le mauvais débat.
Nous devons revenir sur,
quelle est la combinaison de tous ces facteurs
qui va nous apporter ce que nous voulons? (Applaudissements)
Et je veux vous dire quelque chose.
Pour moi, le problème avec l'aide internationale, c'est que...
Je ne pense pas que les Africains doivent maintenant changer complètement d'attitude
et se sentir gênés par l'aide.
L'Afrique a apporté de l'aide aux autres pays.
Mo Ibrahim a dit lors d'un débat auquel nous assistions que --
il rêve du jour où l'Afrique apportera son aide.
Et j'ai dit, "Mo, vous avez raison. Nous avons -- non, mais nous l'avons déjà fait!
Le Royaume-Uni et les Etats-Unis ne pourraient pas exister aujourd'hui sans l'aide de l'Afrique."
(Applaudissements)
Ce sont toutes les ressources qui ont été prises en Afrique,
y compris les hommes, qui ont construit ces pays tels qu'ils existent aujourd'hui!
Donc quand ils essaient de nous rendre quelque chose, nous ne devrions pas être sur la défensive.
Ce n'est pas la question.
La question est comment utilisons-nous ce qu'on nous a donné, ce qu'on nous a rendu.
Comment l'utilisons-nous?
Est-ce que c'est affecté efficacement?
Je veux vous raconter une petite histoire.
Pourquoi ça ne m'ennuie pas de recevoir de l'aide si on l'utilise bien.
De 1967 à 1970, le Nigéria était en guerre - la guerre Nigéria-Biafra.
Et au milieu de cette guerre, j'avais 14 ans.
Nous passions la plupart de notre temps avec ma mère à cuisiner.
Pour l'armée -- mon père s'était engagé comme général de brigade dans l'armée -- l'armé du Biafra.
Nous étions du côté des Biafrais.
Et nous ne faisions plus qu'un repas par jour, fuyant d'un endroit à l'autre,
mais partout où nous pouvions aider nous le faisions.
A un certain moment, en 1969, ça allait vraiment mal.
Nous en étions arrivés à n'avoir presque plus rien pour notre repas quotidien.
Les gens, les enfants mourraient de kwashiorkor.
Je suis sûre que certains d'entre vous qui ne sont plus si jeunes
se rappelleront ces images.
Et bien, j'étais au milieu de tout cela.
Au milieu de tout cela ma mère est tombée malade avec une affection du ventre pendant deux ou trois jours.
Nous pensions qu'elle allait mourir.
Mon père n'était pas là.
Il était dans l'armée.
Donc j'étais la personne la plus vieille dans la maison.
Ma soeur tomba très malade du paludisme.
Elle avait trois ans et j'en avais quinze.
Et elle avait tellement de température -- nous avons tout essayé.
Rien n'avait l'air de vouloir marcher.
Jusqu'à ce qu'on nous dise qu'il y avait un docteur à 10 kilomètres de là, qui pouvait--
qui donnait -- qui examinait les gens et leur donnait des médicaments.
Alors j'ai mis ma soeur sur mon dos -- elle était brûlante --
et j'ai marché 10 kilomètres avec elle attachée sur mon dos.
Il faisait vraiment chaud. J'avais très faim.
J'avais peur car je savais que pour la sauver je devais arriver à l'amener à cette femme.
On nous avait dit qu'il y avait une femme docteur qui soignait les gens.
J'ai marché 10 kilomètres en mettant un pied devant l'autre.
J'arrivai à destination et vis une foule immense.
Il y avait presque mille personnes qui essayaient d'enfoncer la porte.
Elle faisait cela dans une église. Comment allais-je entrer?
Je dus ramper entre les jambes de ces gens
avec ma soeur toujours attachée sur mon dos,
me frayer un chemin jusqu'à une fenêtre.
Et pendant qu'ils essayaient d'enfoncer la porte,
je grimpai par la fenêtre et sautai à l'intérieur.
Cette femme me dit que j'étais arrivée juste à temps.
Le temps que nous sautions dans ce hall, elle ne bougeait presque plus.
Elle lui fit une piqûre de chloroquine -- j'ai appris depuis que c'était de la chloroquine --
lui donna de -- ça devait être pour la réhydrater --
et d'autres traitements, et elle nous mit dans un coin.
Au bout de deux ou trois heures elle commença à bouger.
Et alors, ils l'essuyèrent avec une serviette car elle commençait à transpirer,
ce qui était bon signe.
Et puis ma soeur se réveilla.
Et cinq ou six heures plus tard, elle nous dit que nous pouvions rentrer à la maison.
Je l'attachai sur mon dos.
Je marchai les 10 kilomètres du retour et c'est la marche la plus courte que j'aie jamais faite.
J'étais si heureuse -- (Applaudissements) -- que ma soeur fût vivante!
Aujourd'hui elle a 41 ans, elle est mère de trois enfants,
et elle est médecin et sauve d'autres vies.
Pourquoi je vous raconte ça? Je vous raconte ça parce que --
quand c'est vous -- ou quelqu'un de proche qui est impliqué --
peu vous importe qu'il s'agisse d'aide, ni d'où elle provient.
Vous vous moquez de ce que c'est! (Applaudissements)
Vous voulez juste -- vous voulez juste que la personne vive!
Et maintenant je vais être moins sentimentale et vous dire que sauver des vies,
ce qui est fait sur ce continent avec une partie de l'aide que nous recevons --
quand vous sauvez la vie de quelqu'un, un fermier, un professeur, une mère --
ils contribuent de façon productive à l'économie.
Et en tant qu'économistes, nous pouvons aussi regarder cette histoire de ce point de vue.
Ce sont des gens qui sont des agents de production dans l'économie.
Donc si vous sauvez les gens duVIH, du sida, ou du paludisme,
ça veut dire qu'ils peuvent former la base de la production pour notre économie.
Et de même --
comme quelqu'un l'a dit hier -- si on ne les sauve pas et qu'ils meurent,
leurs enfants deviendront un fardeau pour l'économie.
Donc même d'un point de vue économique,
si on oublie le côté social et humanitaire,
nous avons besoin de sauver des vies maintenant.
Donc c'est une des raisons, née de mon expérience personnelle, de dire, voyons --
canalisons ces ressources que nous avons obtenues vers quelque chose de productif.
Cependant, je vais aussi vous dire que je fais partie de ceux
qui ne croient pas que c'est la seule réponse.
C'est pour cela que je dis que le débat doit être plus sophistiqué.
Vous savez, nous devons l'utiliser à bon escient.
Que s'est-il passé en Europe?
Etes-vous tous au courant que l'Espagne -- qui fait partie de l'UE --
a reçu 10 milliards d'aide du reste de l'UE?
Des ressources qu'on leur a transférées --
et est-ce que les Espagnols en ont eu honte? Non!
L'UE leur a transféré 10 milliards. Où les ont-ils utilisés?
Etes-vous allés dans le sud de l'Espagne dernièrement? Il y a des routes partout.
Des infrastructures partout.
C'est grâce à cela que toute l'Espagne du sud
s'est transformée en une économie de services.
Saviez-vous que l'Irlande a obtenu 3 milliards d'aide?
L'Irlande est un des pays de l'Union Européenne qui a aujourd'hui la croissance la plus rapide.
Dans lequel beaucoup de gens, venant même d'autres régions du monde,
vont pour y trouver du travail.
Qu'ont-ils fait avec ces 3 milliards d'aide?
Ils les ont utilisés pour construire une autoroute de l'information,
obtenir une infrastructure qui leur a permis de participer --
ou leur permet de participer -- à la
révolution informatique.
Et de créer des emplois dans leur économie.
Ils n'ont pas dit, non, vous savez, nous n'allons pas l'accepter.
Aujourd'hui, l'Union Européenne est en train de transférer de l'aide.
Ma frustration est que s'ils peuvent construire des infrastructures en Espagne --
c'est à dire des routes, des nationales, et tout ce qu'ils peuvent construire --
je dis alors, pourquoi refusent-ils d'utiliser cette même aide
pour construire les mêmes infrastructures dans nos pays? (Applaudissements)
Alors que nous leur demandons et nous leur disons de quoi nous avons besoin?
Une de mes inquiétudes aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons maintenant beaucoup de fondations.
Nous parlons maintenant de la Banque Mondiale, du FMI, de responsabilité, etc...
Et de l'UE.
Nous avons aussi maintenant des citoyens privés qui ont beaucoup d'argent.
Certains sont dans l'assistance, avec des fondations privées.
Et un jour ces fondations auront tellement d'argent,
qu'elles dépasseront l'aide officielle qui est distribuée.
Mais j'ai peur -- et je leur suis très reconnaissante à tous
pour ce qu'ils essaient de faire sur ce continent --
mais je suis aussi inquiète. Je me réveille tenaillée par la peur.
Parce que je vois un nouveau type d'entrepreneurs de l'aide internationale sur ce continent.
Et ils vont aussi de pays en pays,
et souvent en essayant de trouver quelque chose à faire.
Mais je ne suis pas vraiment sûre que leur aide
soit canalisée de la bonne manière.
Et beaucoup d'entre eux ne sont pas vraiment familiers avec ce continent.
Ils le découvrent seulement.
Et souvent je ne vois pas d'Africains travaillant avec eux.
Ils travaillent tous seuls dans leur coin! (Applaudissements)
Et souvent j'ai l'impression qu'ils ne s'intéressent même pas vraiment
à ce que les Africains qui pourraient en savoir plus ont à dire.
Ils veulent venir nous voir,
voir ce qu'il se passe sur le terrain, et prendre une décision.
Et peut-être que je suis dure.
Mais je m'inquiète parce que cet argent est tellement important.
Devant qui sont-ils responsables?
Sommes-nous dans leurs conseils quand ils prennent des décisions
sur l'utilisation de l'argent? Sommes-nous là?
Allons-nous refaire les mêmes erreurs que par le passé?
Est-ce que nos présidents et nos dirigeants -- dont tout le monde parle --
est-ce qu'ils n'ont jamais réuni ces gens et dit,
Voyons, votre fondation et votre fondation --
vous avez tellement d'argent, nous sommes reconnaissants.
Asseyons-nous ensemble et nous vous dirons vraiment vers quoi l'argent doit être canalisé
et où cette aide devrait aller."
Avons-nous fait cela? La réponse est non.
Et chacun fait son -- leur propre effort individuel.
Et alors dans 10 ans, des milliards auront à nouveau été dépensés en Afrique,
et nous aurons toujours les mêmes problèmes.
C'est ce qui donne de nous cette image d'un cas désespéré.
Notre incapacité à prendre les choses en main et à dire à tous ces gens qui apportent leur argent:
"Asseyez-vous"
Et nous ne le faisons pas parce que nous sommes trop nombreux. Nous ne nous concertons pas.
Nous n'avons pas appelé les Bill Gate et les Soro--
et tous ceux qui nous aident pour leur dire,
Asseyez-vous. Tenons une conférence avec vous.
En tant que continent, voici nos priorités.
Voici vers quoi nous voulons que cet argent soit canalisé."
Chacun ne devrait pas se comporter en chef d'entreprise,
qui va chercher ce qu'il y a de mieux.
Nous ne sommes pas en train d'essayer de les arrêter. Du tout! Mais de les aider à mieux nous aider.
Et ce qui me déçoit c'est que nous ne fassions pas cela.
Dans dix ans, nous raconterons la même histoire,
et nous répéterons la même chose.
Donc notre problème à l'heure actuelle est de pouvoir utiliser au mieux
toute cette bonne volonté dont on fait preuve envers nous.
Comment pouvons-nous faire pour que le gouvernement s'associe vraiment
avec ces fondations privées, avec les organisations internationales,
et avec notre secteur privé.
Je crois aussi profondément dans le secteur privé.
Mais il n'y arrivera pas tout seul.
Donc nous pouvons peut-être penser à quelques idées qui pourraient marcher.
Ils disent qu'il s'agit de faire proliférer et de partager les idées.
Donc pourquoi ne pensons-nous pas à utiliser une partie de cette aide?
Voyons, pourquoi ne disons-nous pas d'abord à ceux qui nous aident --
n'ayez pas peur des infrastructures!
Cette santé pour laquelle vous travaillez ne peut pas être durable sans infrastructures.
Cette éducation marcherait mieux
si nous avions de l'électricité et des voies ferrées, et ainsi de suite.
Cette agriculture marcherait mieux s'il y avait des voies ferrées pour amener les marchandises au marché.
N'ayez pas peur de ça.
Investissez aussi une partie de vos ressources dans cela.
Et alors nous pouvons voir que cela forme une combinaison
d'argent privé, international, multilatéral,
de secteur privé et d'Africains que nous pouvons faire travailler en partenariat,
pour que l'aide puisse être un facilitateur.
C'est tout ce que l'aide peut espérer être.
L'aide ne peut pas résoudre nos problèmes, j'en suis fermement convaincue.
Mais elle peut jouer le rôle d'un catalyseur. Et si nous n'arrivons pas à l'utiliser comme catalyseur,
nous aurons échoué.
Une des raisons pour lesquelles la Chine est assez populaire avec les Africains actuellement --
une des raisons -- et ce n'est pas juste que, vous savez, ces gens sont stupides
et la Chine vient leur prendre leurs ressources.
C'est parce que nous avons un peu plus d'influence sur les chinois.
Si on leur dit, "Nous avons besoin d'une route ici,"
ils nous aident à la construire.
Ne répugnez pas à construire des infrastructures.
En fait, le ministre des finances chinois m'a dit,
quand je lui ai demandé en quoi nous nous y prenions mal au Nigéria.
Il m'a dit vous n'avez besoin que de deux choses:
Infrastructures, infrastructures, infrastructures -- et discipline.
Vous êtes indisciplinés." (Applaudissements)
Et je le répète pour le continent.
C'est la même chose -- nous avons besoin d'infrastructures, d'infrastructures et de discipline.
Donc nous pouvons fabriquer un catalyseur qui nous aide à nous en munir.
Bon je réalise que -- je ne dis pas que -- la santé et l'éducation --
non, vous pouvez aussi fournir cela.
Mais je dis que ce n'est pas l'un ou l'autre.
Voyons comment l'aide peut être un facilitateur, en partenariat.
Une idée.
Deuxièmement, pour le secteur privé.
Les gens ont peur de prendre des risques sur ce continent.
Pourquoi n'utilisons-nous pas une partie de cette aide comme une sorte de mécanisme de garantie,
pour permettre aux gens de prendre des risques?
(Applaudissements)
Et enfin, parce qu'ils sont tous les deux à ma - j'ai fini- je n'ai plus le temps.
Est-ce qu'il me reste du temps?
OK, alors il ne faut pas que j'oublie le mot de la fin.
Une des choses pour laquelle je veux la collaboration de tous est
d'aider les femmes, à créer des emplois. (Applaudissements)
On a beaucoup dit sur les femmes, ce n'est pas la peine que je le répète.
Mais il y a des gens -- des femmes -- qui créent des emplois.
Et nous savons, les études ont montré
que quand vous mettez des ressources dans les mains d'une femme,
en fait, il y a une étude économétrique --
un rapport de la banque mondiale fait en 2000 -- qui montre que
les transferts dans les mains des femmes donnent
des enfants en meilleure santé, plus pour le foyer, plus pour l'économie et tout cela.
Donc je ne dis pas qu'une des idées à emporter d'ici --
Je ne dis pas que les hommes ne sont pas importants --
de toute évidence si vous laissez les maris en dehors, que vont-ils faire?
Ils vont rentrer à la maison et être de mauvaise humeur,
et cela va créer des problèmes dont nous ne voulons pas.
Nous ne voulons pas que les hommes battent leur femme
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de travail, et ainsi de suite.
Mais en marge,nous pouvons aussi - je veux en faire une priorité-
pour la raison que, les hommes automatiquement--
ils obtiennent -- pas automatiquement mais ils ont tendance à obtenir plus d'aide.
Mais je veux que vous réalisiez que les ressources,
dans les mains des femmes africaines, constituent un outil puissant.
Il y a des gens qui créent des emplois --
Béatrice Gakuba a créé 200 emplois à partir de son affaire de fleurs au Rwanda.
Nous avons Ibukun Awosika au Nigeria, avec les meubles -- sa société de chaises.
Elle veut s'agrandir.
Elle a besoin de 20 millions supplémentaires.
Elle va créer 100, 200 emplois supplémentaires.
Donc partez d'ici en réfléchissant à comment vous allez trouver
les ressources pour mettre de l'argent dans les mains de femmes
qui sont prêtes:
des femmes d'affaires qui veulent s'agrandir et créer plus d'emplois.
Et enfin, qu'allez-vous faire
pour faire partie de ce partenariat avec l'aide, le gouvernement, le secteur privé
et les Africains, vous en tant qu'individu?
Merci. (Applaudissements)